says we just heard families across the
country are facing new challenges
as this pandemic forces many students to
begin the school year remotely
hopefully they're not using deaths that
look like they were from the last
century
we met stay-at-home mom her name is
kieran walia and her two sons their name
ishan
and arman so they are starting high
school and the fifth grade from their
porter ranch
that's in california the family shared
their daily challenges and triumphs with
us
as they try to navigate this new normal
of remote learning
are you ready to wake up yeah no this is
what our typical morning looks like
these unprecedented times have created a
new
norm ishan is in the middle of his zoom
meeting
in preparation for his freshman year in
high school
i'm just nervous not about going into a
new school but
how the teachers adapted to online
learning
armand is working diligently on his
math homework what i like about doing
school from home
is that my teacher gives nice fabulous
comments about me
the worst part of online learning is
that i can't see my teacher
i can't play with my friends and i
don't have research or lunch how's your
lunch
[Music]
i can sense that the kids feel the
isolation
mom it's your turn i am definitely
concerned that the kids are not learning
enough
in virtual school i am scared
it's a very difficult time
we have to keep the kids positive we
have to keep them
motivated we have to teach them not to
be afraid
[Music]
and that's a that's a portrait of one
family's attempt to learn
remotely we're going to talk to sal khan
now i want to welcome him in he's the
founder and ceo of khan academy that's a
non-profit
educational organization that provides
free online lessons for children of all
ages and also resources for parents and
teachers i've used them they're
wonderful you should check it out
he joins us now saul good morning i want
to give
parents some concrete tips for kids of
of all ages but
let's begin by just setting expectations
we know that online learning is not as
good as in-person learning
but can we do it better than we've been
doing it
yeah i think and we have to do it better
because this this looks like it's going
to be protracted school closures
and so the key is is not to set
expectations too high because that'll
just set everyone up for a stress and
disappointment and this is a time where
we have enough things to stress about
especially for parents if parents are
stressed out
then kids are going to feel stressed out
and they're going to have a harder time
learning
so the key thing is focus on the basics
obviously everyone school is supporting
them
to different degrees but especially if
your kids can get their math
their reading the writing depending on
the age of the student it can be
anywhere from 20 minutes a day
up to maybe two sessions or three
sessions of 20 or 30 minutes a day
if you can get that under your belt and
then you get your legs under you then
you can think about layering on more
subjects
yeah okay so let's talk about those
students for the younger kids grade
ages three to seven what should the
parental strategy be
for making sure they don't fall behind
yeah and this you know a lot of times
when we talk about distant school we
imagine school is first and foremost
about learning the academic standards
and it is that is what we associate
school for
but as you just saw in that last segment
school is also about the connections the
social emotional learning the connection
with the teacher
and so everything you do for your child
or if you're a teacher for the student
is try to optimize those connections so
i would say for a very young student we
have early learning app khan academy
kids it's free it's non-commercial all
funded by philanthropy
kids can work on that for 20 minutes a
day ideally they're doing that next to a
parent they're able to
still stay connected while they're doing
distance learning hopefully their
teachers are able to do a couple of
20-minute zoom sessions or video
conference sessions
every day and then those should be
pulling the students out of the screen
as much as possible getting them to do
interactive things especially for that
younger age group getting them to move
around even
yeah what about kids there in the middle
maybe ages 8 to 13. you know the
challenge there isn't getting them
online it's getting them off of the
video games and talking to their friends
and focusing on school what's the
strategy for those guys
yeah you know and i i have three kids
eleven nine and five so i'm kind of
you know straddling these age brackets
and you're absolutely right i think the
key there is
try to set goals with them try to
understand what's achievable in the day
a lot of those teachers who are doing
this well are doing exactly that
they're setting goals for the day
they're setting goals for the week
they're doing
regular check-ins and when they get in
on google hangout or google meet or they
get on zoom or whatever video conference
they're using
instead of it just being about a one-way
lecture-based interaction
they've got to really pull them out ask
them questions ask them to work on video
conference breakouts
do some goal setting with them do some
small group sessions and not just
between the student and the teacher as
you heard from the last segment it's
super important that students are able
to interact with each other as well
and if you're not seeing that from your
child's school try to get some of that
outside of whatever is being provided
you could do socially distance play
dates in the park whatever especially
i would say all ages that social
interaction even for us adults
is super important yeah
all right so thank you very much and i
want to say that it's great to hear your
voice live i heard it uh remotely uh on
one of your lessons just last week
you were giving me a tutorial to help my
fifth grader on order of operations
always tricky for a rising sixth grader
if you didn't pay attention in class
anyway thank you very much anthony
tossing it back to you
all right thank you both